[Music]
after decades of restoration efforts
wolves are once again roaming parts of
the western US the return of the animals
is not without controversy and a
remarkable new book examines the issues
involved from a unique perspective
through the life story of one of the
animals American wolf a true story of
survival and obsession in the West is by
author Nate Blakesley Nate good morning
and welcome good morning thanks for
having me so let's talk about the
reintroduction of the wolves to
Yellowstone National Park in 1995 how
did that happen and how successful was
it wolves were eliminated from
Yellowstone as they were from most of
the lower 48 by the end of the 19th
century and what happened in Yellowstone
was you saw this huge explosion in the
elk population that is the wolf's main
prey and there was nothing left to prey
on them and so in turn the habitat in
Yellowstone started to degrade
opportunities for other species were
lost because the elk you've probably
heard the expression the mountain fears
the elk like the elk here's the wolf the
idea that bringing wolves back might
solve this problem was first came up in
the 1940s but it was controversial and
the federal government wasn't able to
get it done until the mid 90s when they
did bring them back it was immensely
successful so much so that today the
debate is over whether or not they are
well established enough to begin hunting
them again Wow
the hero of this book is a wolf named oh
six what mate oh six so special oh six
his story captivated the world during
the time that that she was sort of the
queen of Yellowstone she was the most
visible wolf in the park at a time when
wolf watching became very popular and
Facebook was also exploding so her image
was everywhere I met this small group of
wolf watching fanatics in the park
people who come to the park every day
and track wolves and follow them with
their scopes and in particular I met
this one woman Laurie Lyman a retired
San Diego schoolteacher she gave me this
treasure trove of notes that she had
collected about oh six and her pack over
three years I read it it was like
reading the diary of a wolf pack and the
author in me said what you could do with
this material you could write a
nonfiction book that reads like a novel
in which the characters are wolves like
a Jack London store
except it's all true and well I don't
want to give any spoilers away but you
know the reintroduction of wolves is not
without controversy there are some
environmentalists on one side business
owners livestock owners who don't like
the reintroduction of wolves tell us
about the tension there
yes the same ranchers that eliminated
wolves generations ago their descendants
are still there and they still fear
losing cattle and sheep to wolves and
elk hunting is really big business in
the Northern Rockies and wolves eat a
lot of elk so there was a concern there
and also the politics around wolves has
become really poisonous it's become this
sort of us versus them this federal
government versus local control the
cultural issue isn't it in some ways it
is yeah the governor of Idaho butch
Otter he famously ran on a campaign of
promising to eliminate as many wolves
from Idaho as he could just as soon as
they came off the endangered species but
at the same time wolves have actually
kind of balanced the environment there
haven't been yes one of the goals as I
said of bringing wolves back 20 years
ago was to restore Yellowstone to fix
Yellowstone and now we've seen it this
biologists call it a trophic cascade you
you bring back the apex predator all of
a sudden there's fewer elk which in turn
means the habitat rebounds it's meant
healthier streams more fish more beavers
one of the first things that happened is
the coyote population plummeted because
wolves preyed on coyotes it brought
rodents back which in turn brought
Eagles back and it's just been this
endless cascade of positive effects a
fascinating neat Blakesley thank you so
much for being with us thank you I
appreciate it
the book is American wolf